hello everyone and welcome back to
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong the weekly
podcast where we take the Tomato Meter
and say wait a minute is that movie
really that good or come on there's no
way that movie's that bad I'm usually
joined by my beloved co-host Jacqueline
Coley she's under the weather right now
she just says they're a little bug
nothing to be too concerned about is
what I'm is what my sources tell me but
she's not feeling up to broadcasting
today and we're talking about some
really scary stuff on this show this
particular week we're talking about some
spookiness we're talking about some
creatures that may kind of crawl into
your brain and just never really leave
because that's the kind of ear worms the
Guillermo del Toro plants every time he
makes a picture they're not always
horror movies how sometimes they're
family fables but they always tend to be
a little darker in the storytelling and
a little more exotic with the creature
Creations because it is the genius of
garamadol Taurus so we're going to be
talking about that in celebration of a
couple different things I mean first of
all it's the Halloween season all right
the pumpkin spice it's wafting in the
air so these are the kind of movies that
we like celebrating particularly this
time of year and then we also have
National Hispanic Heritage Month and
Guillermo del Toro has a new Netflix
show called Cabinet of Curiosities that
comes out I believe this month as well
and then he also has the Pinocchio movie
a very different spin on Pinocchio that
comes out in December of 2022. I want to
talk about that trailer with our special
guest by the way and so I want to give a
shout out before we bring in our guests
before we do anything else to not just
Guillermo del Toro and his amazing
filmography but also to our very own
Alex VOE who curated a wonderful
editorial that is the top 10 Guillermo
del Toro movies ranked by Tomato Meter
technically there's 11 movies on there
but uh I'm just gonna say Blade 2 didn't
quite make the cut we love you blade too
we love you didn't quite make the cut
um so we also are going to be counting
down the audience score versus the
Tomato Meter what we think is accurate
we think is isn't that's what we do here
on this show so if you want to check out
the editorial by Alex you can go to
rottentomatoes.com and now without
further Ado here are the top 10 movies
according to the Tomato Meter directed
by Guillermo del Toro at number one
should be no surprise that it is Pan's
Labyrinth the landmark
fairy tale film from 2006 95 certified
Fresh The Devil's Backbone is number two
93 certified fresh the shape of water
the oscar-winning film from 2017 is 92
percent certified fresh at number four
we go way way back to 1993's Kronos the
sort of Debut feature film of Del Toro
that's 89 certified fresh at number five
and number six respectively our Hellboy
2 the Golden Army and then Hellboy so
that's 86 percent for Hellboy 2 81 for
Hellboy number seven is the recently
released nightmare alley which has a
really cool Black and White Edition 80
certified fresh at the number eight spot
is Crimson Peak 73 certified fresh I
don't know if it's certified fresh it
might just be fresh I don't know Crimson
Peak you might be on Shaky Ground you're
fresh for now as is number Nine's
Pacific Rim which is 72 percent fresh
and then we close out the top 10 with
mimic from 1997. 64 percent for rash the
only one that didn't make the top 10 is
Blade 2 and that's also the only rotten
film that del Toro's ever directed to
this point 57 percent rod and I write
enough math enough of me talking
percentages and numerals let's bring in
not only one of my favorite guests not
only one of my favorite people on Earth
but just I I think this is the perfect
guess for this episode because she loves
all things that are scary all things
that are dark all things that are
Fantastical and she is herself dark
Fantastical and mysterious the one the
only you know her is one of the creators
of the World Girls podcast and their
spin-off show [ __ ] out of water it is
dorina Ariano dorina welcome back to
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong lovely to see
you hola hola always happy to be here
you forgot to also say that it's the
perfect episode to bring me in because I
too and Mexicana like uh the Masterpiece
of a man that we're talking about here
so very proud to be here very happy to
be back uh with the Rotten Tomatoes crew
thanks for having me yeah and and you
know you bring up his Heritage and it
was such a landmark Oscar's moment when
he won
um for the shape out of the shape of
water and and that film won best picture
at the academy awards ceremony I think
you and I might have been watching that
together I think that might have been
back in our collider days where we got
together at the actual office and we
were watching the broadcast that night
it was just such a cool moment because
we I mean regardless what you think of
shape of water and I've heard some
varying takes on it that I agree with
both ways but Del Toro himself he's just
such a lovable joyous guy and so to see
him get acclaimed to see him be able to
hold a statue and have it be so full of
meaning for him it was so cool to watch
yeah I especially love the moment where
obvious I think the year prior was the
hilarious Oscar year of uh where they
messed up uh and thought that La La Land
won the Frozen envelope a really
Moonlight one and so I think Guillermo
goes up to Warren Beatty to get the
Oscar and he doesn't even hug him he
actually like grabs uh the the letter
from him to make sure that he actually
won and he's so happy about it and super
cute and then he hugs Warren Beatty I
love that moment but yes so happy that
uh as much as you know there there's
obviously political turmoil uh in
America love that we have several
Mexican directors winning for uh Oscar
for best director yeah yeah absolutely I
mean you talk about Alfonso Quran you
talk about guiller Del Toro and it
really does paint a picture for you as
to just sort of the artistic upbringing
that they had in their home country and
you see so many of those fingerprints in
Del Toro work specifically I mean you go
all the way back to Chrome know so you
talk about the Devil's Backbone Pan's
Labyrinth so we're going to talk about
all these movies when I read off the the
ranking of Del Toro movies by Tomato
Meter is there like one thing that stood
out to you where you're like wait wait
wait wait wait that feels a little off
well you know I usually very much
disagree with Rotten Tomatoes I am
shocked that Rotten Tomatoes seems to be
correct for once uh because I think I
mostly agree with this list I've never
ever agreed and so I'm very surprised uh
I I definitely think pan slapper this is
his best movie by far uh but I don't
hate any of his movies I even think
Blade 2 has some fun moments uh if
anything I think that my least favorite
and this might make people sad a
specific Rim so I might put that a
little bit lower uh as a Kaiju fan I
wanted more Kaiju as opposed to the
human story so uh I yeah Pacific Rim's
not my favorite I would put that much
lower than ever everything else but I
mostly agree with this movie with this
ranking yeah I I kind of have this
similar feelings for a specific Rim
which is surprising if you've ever
talked to me for five minutes but I'm
also so and I want you to shed some
light on this later in the show when we
get into movie talk about uh Crimson
Peak and how maybe that movie was just a
little mismarketed and it actually was
something else the whole time so we have
a lot to get into here with Del Toro and
his body of work and then at the end I
do want to leave a little bit of time to
talk about his work as an executive
producer as a screenwriter just a force
behind the scenes as well because he's
worked on a lot of films that he didn't
necessarily direct but they're films
that we know and we hold dear so without
further Ado let's first turn it over to
Tim Ryan he's the expert curation uh
manager here he does all the reviews at
Rotten Tomatoes kind of uh Aggregates
all of them and funnels them into the
Tomato Meter he's one of the many folks
that makes this engine called Rotten
Tomatoes hum so let's turn it over to
Tim for his segment two minutes with Tim
humans with Tim okay so here's a very
brief overview of Guillermo del Toro's
filmography his best reviewed film is
Pan's Labyrinth from 2006 which is
certified fresh at 95 on the Tomato
Meter with 241 reviews and it has a 91
audience score number two is the Devil's
Backbone from 2001 which is certified
fresh at 93 with 120 reviews and it has
an 89 audience score and number three is
Best Picture Winner the shape of water
from 2017 which is certified fresh at 92
percent with 462 reviews and it has a 72
audience score his worst reviewed is
Blade 2 which is rotten at 57 with 150
reviews though it does have a 68
audience score and a pretty substantial
cult following all I'm saying is Blade 2
is your worst reviewed movie you've had
a pretty outstanding career so what did
the critics have to say in a fresh
review for Pan's Labyrinth David Germain
of the Associated Press wrote Guillermo
del Toro has crafted a masterpiece a
terrifying visually wondrous fairy tale
for adults that plans fantasy and gloomy
drama into one of the most magical films
to come along in years however in a
rotten review for Blade 2 Jack Matthews
of the New York daily news wrote Del
Toro is a stylish horror meister and he
has created an evocative foreboding
atmosphere but only a fan of this kind
of Mayhem could find a way into the
story
so that's a very brief look at Guillermo
del Toro and I just want to say that the
one time I met him he seemed really nice
back to you folks
thank you Tim you're very nice as well
the many times I've gotten to meet you I
want to say I met germa Del Toro Once
Upon a Time darina have you ever had the
pleasure of meeting the man no
um I was actually in the same room as
him but you know me I don't like going
to bother people and saying hi uh and uh
even though I I actually did do that
with Diego Luna because I'm like oh he's
he wasn't famous yet in America and and
I speak Spanish so we were able to talk
same with us Isaac but but uh with
Guillermo I it was like his q a uh I
actually think it was four shape of
water so I was like I'm not gonna do
that thing where I'm like let me go talk
to him while he's you know being uh run
amug by fans so uh but uh I do very nice
thing about you is Adrena never bothers
famous people because she's too busy
getting into the after party before
anybody else is carrying the wristbands
you also gotta you know make sure you're
well everybody's trying to talk to the
celebrities I am at the buffet eating
the food that nobody's eating so so um
priorities here but no I I totally agree
with Tim I hear that a Guillermo is a
lovely person and I like to think that
most Mexican horror fans like ourselves
are pretty nice people because we grew
up in a very you know messed up way and
uh as Guillermo Toro has been asked
before I don't know if you saw his
interview where they were like Hey how
do you balance the dark with the good or
something like that and he just goes I'm
Mexican like he's like no one lives
loves life more than we do because we
know we're gonna die so we have a very
similar philosophies let's go into movie
talk right now because I want to keep
talking about this so hit the music
Brian
it is movie talk not necessarily
religion talk but it's hard to separate
the two when you talk about Del Toro
because a lot of times our fables our
fairy tales our mythology is rooted in
religious Concepts but before we get
into any of these specific movies and I
know Dorena I I want to get your
thoughts on Pan's Labyrinth on Crimson
Peak on nightmare alley all these movies
what was the first time that Del Toro
came on your radar you know it's a
really bizarre uh thing that probably
people have not heard of outside of
Mexico but um his first feature film was
Chronos which was in I think 93 so I
definitely saw that as his first movie
but in Mexico when I was a kid in the
80s like in the late 80s there was a
show similar to The Twilight Zone that
was called Laura marcada I guess it
would translate to the marked hour and
Guillermo El Toro along with other
famous uh Mexican filmmakers like cuaron
they all were part of the show and and
they basically just brought in you know
like creepy kind of sci-fi horror uh
episodes uh I think including one of
them made like a Stephen King short
story and it was a very short-lived
um TV show or TV series that was not
meant for kids but obviously you know
nobody cares down there so I I would
watch it at night and freak out and I
loved it and later as an adult I figured
out oh Guillermo I thought it was behind
this so it was a pretty cool thing to
not even know that I was watching a man
that I would grow up to admire Kronos
never hit my radar as as a kid
um like when it came out back in 93 and
it has a very young Ron Perlman in it
and and it's a wonderful movie by the
way it's great but I remember seeing
trailers for mimic and Mira Sorvino
being the star of it and just you know
even the critic response like as the
movie's coming out you know they always
have like critics are saying this but I
remember them saying just how original
it was and and and how spooky it was and
how well crafted the story was and so
it's like okay who is behind this again
this is a German otorro guy and then
Blade Two comes out but it really wasn't
until Pan's Labyrinth that you sort of
realize that this guy is is really
something special in the world of
Storytelling and because I remember the
Hellboy the first Hellboy film had come
out and it just didn't really hit my
radar at that time but Pan's Labyrinth
sure did because everybody was talking
about it and it ends up having this
Legacy of being his highest rated film
on the Tomato Meter 95 certified fresh
91 audience score what is it to you
darina about Pan's Labyrinth that makes
it worthwhile as far as being at the top
of such a celebrated filmmaker's
filmography well I think
in every single movie that Guillermo has
made uh he's basically immersing Us in
this fantasy world with ghosts and
Fantastical creatures and monsters but
at the end of the day all of his stories
remind us that the scariest monsters are
the humans right and so which we can
obviously all relate especially nowadays
in the world that we live in and so the
beautiful thing about Penn's Labyrinth
is that
um it not only is just a visually
stunning film and uh it's one of my
favorite scores by Javier navarrete who
also did Devil's Backbone and he's
worked with him before uh but um it's
it's just such a it I don't know if you
saw Devil's Backbone but they're both
similar right where uh this is the dose
backbone is about a little boy that is
uh basically living through the Spanish
Civil War and in Penn's Labyrinth it's a
little girl that's living through that
and so the kind of contrast of having
you know the the the boys or in my
opinion the fascism is a is a male
concept right and so uh seeing that
Through The Eyes of this little girl
that has nowhere else to go and she'll
see she's kind of dreamed of this
fantasy world to escape uh you know
these evil dudes that are basically uh
following and rooting for a dictator
which later became to be a Francisco
Franco
it's it's just such a it it's such a
heart-wrenching movie it's so it's so
freaking sad but at the same time it's
inspiring because
um it I guess the the concept of humans
continuing to dream and imagine can
sometimes still overcome the horrible
things that that uh people can do and
and just visually I think what really
sold Pan's Labyrinth what was one of the
the cogs in the machine that got it on
people's writer initially was the look
of the creatures because you hear it's
this fairy tale and and it's set back in
a war-torn era but seeing the creatures
particularly Pale Man just the look of
Pale Man where you have eyes on your
hands and then you know he could put
them in so it kind of looks like he's
human but then he removes them and
you're like what the hell is this thing
and then you hear the shriek the the
scream from Pale Man like you see stuff
like that and then you have pan slash
the Fawn which is an awesome look you
have the fairies flying around it was
just it looked like nothing that we had
ever seen before and it felt so holy
original and again this came out in the
mid 2000s and so this is a time where
your big Blockbusters were starting to
be comic book movies they didn't really
have them all you know lined up together
like you get with the MCU now but you
would see stuff that you had heard of
before that you'd read in comic books
Pan's Labyrinth Arena was like nothing
I'd ever seen none of the creatures felt
familiar it all felt so fresh and so new
and I think that's one of the reasons
why people kept coming back to it well
and it's it's basically kind of like
makes you feel uh like when you were a
kid and you were watching fantasy movies
like you know a never-ending story or uh
Labyrinth or any of those uh movies when
you're when you're kids that are more
about actually family films and then now
you get to see Penn's lab Pen's
Labyrinth which is about a little girl
but it's a very you know adult oriented
film because it's actually really scary
not just the creatures that you're
mentioning but the true villains which
are the humans right and so um I I
completely agree with you that for me it
was like it made me feel like a little
kid it made me feel scared it made me
feel uh hopeful at the same time
bringing me back to kind of like I was
watching a movie when I was a little kid
in the 80s right except this time it was
2006 and I was an adult uh eating my
popcorn because I was so stressed out
yeah I mean as the as the wonderful band
Foreigner would say it feels like the
first time and in that it was like the
first time I went back to the movies it
was like the first time I was in a movie
theater because I just saw it on a whim
I had heard some things about it and it
just completely blew me away how
immersive this this ethereal sort of
presence was and you just felt it
throughout the run time of the film but
I'm glad you brought up the Devil's
Backbone too because I it's number two
as far as the rating goes and I feel
like Devil's Backbone has earned that
right and I don't think enough people
talk about this film now because it's so
vintage Del Toro in that it is super
scary at moments but there is a
sweetness to it there is that there's a
rooting interest you're watching it sort
of Through The Eyes of a child but the
scene in Devil's background it always
gives me is is is when this kid Carlos
is at this new school there's this this
young ghost that's sort of wandering the
grounds and you don't really know is it
is it a force of good is it a force of
evil the first time he starts seeing
these apparitions it's so well crafted
and it freaks through the F out but you
also can't turn the movie off at that
point because you have to unravel the
rest of this mystery totally and um it's
uh it's crazy because I completely agree
there's that scene where I think the uh
Santi the Little Ghost kid is following
Carlos uh in the hallway and then Carlos
hides in this room and closes the door
and it seems like the ghost is trying to
like get into the door and then he looks
in the uh the door hole and you and all
of a sudden the ghost uh kid's eye shows
up like that's a such a good uh jump
scare seat even though I don't think
Guido actually likes doing those but um
I just it just one it was one of those
things I remember watching in the
theater in Mexico and everybody jumped
and freaked out so
foreign
also at the same time even though it can
be scary it's literally like other than
Pan's Labyrinth the saddest horror movie
ever made like that's the thing about
his movies right that they are they're
horror movies but they're they're
basically a lot of them are about war
seen through an innocent kid's eyes so
it's it's a b it's beautiful and
heartbreaking at the same time that it's
scary yeah and it reminded me I guess
this movie came out in 2001 and then I
hadn't seen it until I had until after
I'd already seen a film that Del Toro
executive produced I don't think it's
nearly enough love and that's the
orphanage because they kind of felt like
similar tones but I saw the orphanage
first and like I remember walking out of
that thing just being like what the hell
did I just see this was so good and so
to see the devil's backwards he sort of
you know is something that clearly might
have inspired the orphanage it's a
really good double feature if y'all are
the kids are done trick-or-treating and
you got all the candy that you bought
for the kids and they didn't claim so
now it's yours sit down and I think it's
a pretty good double feature with the
Devil's Backbone into the orphanage
except the orphanage is actually I think
pretty scary like it's it's one of the
scary
yeah no breaking news exactly well there
dude the scene where the grandma uh is
uh walking through the street with the
carriage or whatever it is and then and
then she gets hit that was amazing that
was really well done I think it's
actually one of the scariest things that
I've shown people that they hate me for
it's similar to The Descent
oh
[Music]
ready now
the descent's another good one too and
again if you're able to get a scare out
of darina then you're you're doing
something right or or very very wrong um
if I if I give you just sort of the
landscape of del Toro's filmography and
you can toss Blade 2 into this I don't
think you'll need to it what is the
scariest movie that he directed in your
opinion what is the one that scares you
the most is it the Devil's Backbone
because of some of those sort of against
type jump scares is it just Pan's
Labyrinth because of the the sort of
philosophical uh religious sort of
component to it or is it something else
yeah I think I don't that's the thing
about the daughter is that he grew up
like me just being fascinated by
monsters and loving uh you know he
worships Mary Shelley's Frankenstein
right like uh which Frankenstein uh as a
movie isn't really that scary but the
concept of it is scary right so I think
uh the two that you brought up are the
scariest one in in those two concepts
like Devil's Backbone has these like
really creepy kid that you don't know
like you said if he's good or bad so
like you don't know when he's gonna show
up so the it as as a as a ghost movie
it's very
um I think it's a pretty it's a really
good Ghost movie versus uh Pan's
Labyrinth the pale man is like my
favorite guillermotoro creature uh like
you described him like he's actually
like pretty scary looking and and uh
shout out to Doug Jones because he
always plays the coolest scariest
creatures best uh but uh but the
scariest villain I think in in or one of
the scariest villains in movie history
is is the stepdad you know he's
literally an evil fascist stepdad like
he's I think he's one of the most
horrific characters in a movie ever so
uh he scared me the most out of any of
Guillermo El Toro's villains I will say
mimic has a really good suspenseful
moment though on the subway where it's
not it's not Mira soravino jogging away
from she's not walking quickly she's
full on sprinting away from whatever
this thing is and that movie really just
it's a good tool I think for young
filmmakers to watch and just learn how
to craft suspense and how to make a
scene tense and you know if we go back
into sort of the the Del Toro
filmography I think you pivot away from
horror as far as the jump scares go but
something you hit on earlier to Reina is
that a lot of times regardless of all
the Fantastical scary looking creatures
in Del Toro movies the humans are really
the problem here and I think that that's
best exemplified by his number three
movie on the Tomato Meter and that is
the shape of water which which won the
Oscar and so you see how evil how
twisted humans can be whether it's
against minorities whether it's against
uh fish people it there's a whole lot of
evil going on mainly from human beings
in that and then you get so much
backlash because the film is so popular
and won all these Awards and his 92
certified fresh about how it's a little
weird that Sally Hawkins is banging a
fish in a bathtub let's be honest with
what we saw where do you land on the
shape of water now is it is it worthy of
being his number three is it worthy of
being 92 percent winning the Oscar all
that stuff look story-wise it's not my
favorite it's a very simple story it
really is a monster love story at the
end of the day and some people could say
it's a bestiality I guess but but it it
look if Bohemian Rhapsody can be
nominated for several Oscars any movie
can win okay so shape of water is
visually stunning the score by Alexander
de Splat is one of is gorgeous uh and so
even if you don't care about the story
it's it because it's such a simple Love
Story Michael Shannon is one of the
coolest living actors and such a such a
great villain and it I just kind of felt
like I was watching an old school uh
Hollywood fantasy movie like from the
back in the day before we were born
right so um I don't mind that this one a
bunch of crappy movies have won Oscars
who cares this is great it's the same
sort of environment that I feel like a
nightmare alley placed Us in where you
instantly felt like you were in a
different era of Hollywood why watching
this movie and we all have jokes about
her sleeping with the fish but at the
end of the day she wasn't exactly
killing it on Tinder you know and and
this fit like you could go back and film
more to the Creature from the Black
Lagoon who I'm just gonna say arguably
the best mate for that for that lovely
lady you know I mean because again the
Creature from the Black Lagoon was in
love was smitten and what was sort of
falling for this person I don't know
that any male that's walking on land is
going to be a better fit because we know
most men are garbage so I don't have a
big issue with her choosing this fish
person because I think the fish person
brings loyalty
um you're gonna have to address it at
the holidays with your family but I
think that ultimately it is a very
simple love story and I love that this
film felt like it was marketed more
properly towards what the subject matter
was and I think that's why I got so much
love as opposed to something like
Crimson Peak where it felt like they
were selling it as a straight up haunted
house scarifest which was not the
intention of that movie at all if
anything Crimson Peak is more more of a
love story along the lines of the shape
of water than it is something like the
Devil's Backbone totally I actually have
very much switched my gears on Crimson
Peak because of that because it was I
thought I was gonna go see one of
Guillermo tour's scariest movies and it
ended up being a love incest story so I
was very confused but but it looked so
cool that I was like whatever man like
this looks amazing it's a beautiful
looking movie like all his movies
um but yeah it I I think uh I I don't
actually know if I re now that I've
rewatched them if I like Crimson Peak or
shape of water better but I think you're
right that um they're they're similar in
that sense it's just that Crimson Peak
is more Gothic Horror versus uh shape of
water to me is like a straight up love
story I think that's probably why my
simple brain appreciates the shape of
water more because I re-watch Crimson
Peak in prep for this episode because I
do remember just feeling deflated and it
was sort of the similar vibe that I had
walking out of them Night Shyamalan film
The Village where I can go back and
watch The Village down I think I even
said it on this podcast like I really
appreciate the village and what it did
and now it's suddenly one of my favorite
Shyamalan movies because of what that
movie was doing not what the marketing
was trying to do to you it was trying to
manipulate you into thinking you're
seeing something else I think the same
problem befell Crimson Peak but also
going back and watching it maybe I'm
just not a Gothic romance kind of guy to
Arena I I couldn't get into the story as
much as I would want to given that it's
a Del Toro film with all those insanely
cool visuals it's just nothing ever
really grabbed me and so if there was
one that I might have to kick out of the
top 10 and put Blade 2 in I think
Crimson Peak might be that movie and
it's not because I felt misdirected it's
just because again watching it now it
just it doesn't doesn't really grab me
the same way and I'm not really sure why
I mean look not you can't be into
everything it's okay that you're not
into Gothic horror but me being into
both of us being really into Kai Jew and
loving monsters and loving monsters
fighting I'm very surprised that I think
Pacific Rim is still my least favorite
on this list uh not because it's I don't
think it's a bad movie I just I just I
just think it's one of his least
exciting movies even though people love
it so much I just wanted to see the
Kaiju fighting I want I was like give me
Godzilla don't give me this human story
so uh at least for Crimson Peak uh you
get to see like these really this really
cool like creature woman you know like
crawling through the hallways and uh
there's just it I don't care if the plot
sucks or if you're not into the story as
much but as long as you give me visually
stunning uh cinematography like
constantly and production design and set
design and all that I'm good like I will
enjoy that more than not being able to
watch a monster a cool Kaiju fight
because they're underwater see that's
why I bumped Pacific Rim ahead of
Crimson Peak for that theory reason
because I feel like the way that the
fights are choreographed between the
Kaiju and the Yeagers in Pacific Rim is
awesome because again this movie came
out and we were still in the thick of
these Michael Bay Transformers films
that just became bigger disaster after a
bigger disaster you go back to
Transformers three Dark of the Moon
right and there's a fight in Chicago
that's the climax of the movie and it
takes like 45 minutes and you can't
really tell what the hell is going on
you can't tell who's an Autobot who's a
Decepticon it's just a bunch of mashed
potatoes and then you watch something
like Pacific Rim and they're doing like
mixed martial arts moves and you can see
it you can see everything even though
it's dark and they're underwater
sometimes and it's a storm you can still
see what's happening so I loved all that
with Pacific Rim my biggest issue with
Pacific Rim during Arena you hit on it
earlier I do not care about any of the
humans I honestly don't think any of the
performances are all that noteworthy
with the exception of Idris Elba for two
reasons one because his name is stacker
Pentecost which is arguably the coolest
name in the history of names and he also
does does have a nice Independence Day
Bill Pullman's speech moment that I
don't think Rises to the level of id4
but it's a pretty good speech if you put
on the the sort of you know right before
the the climactic battle scene speech
that he puts it's a pretty good workout
prep you know is to just you're ready to
run through a brick wall after that
thing even though you don't really care
about any of the humans in this movie
today there's not a man no woman in here
that shall stand alone
not today
we Face the monsters that are at our
door
I'm bringing the fight to them
today we are canceling the Apocalypse
look people anybody that's thinking of
directing a future Kaiju movie just give
us Godzilla man we don't care about the
humans we just want to see monsters
fight Godzilla Godzilla versus Kong was
pretty much like that even though people
thought it was bad I don't care I got to
see super cool creatures monsters
fighting so give me that now Mark let me
ask you a question because we both seem
to really not want to put Blade 2 out of
this uh and I'm wondering why because
for me like Blade 2 is obviously not his
best movie but I love blade in general
so maybe that's why I have like a soft
you know uh a room in his in my heart
for the for this movie even though it's
not the best but just basically when
Kris Kristofferson like tosses his uh
his black shades from the balcony and
Wesley Snipes like kind of gets his mojo
back at the climax of the movie like
stupid like that is oh can I even cuss
in here I don't even remember um feel
free stupid stuff like that is basically
like what I'm I'm like oh you know what
this is a fun movie I don't care but
what about so so if we want to bring
that back what about mimic then because
that's kind of a controversial movie as
well yeah it mimic is and and del Toro's
got a great line about it that he said
I'll paraphrase him and butcher it but
he was talking about making mimic and
he's like you know I had two really bad
things happen to me uh when I was making
mimic is that and this is true his
father was kidnapped and then he also
had to work with with Harvey Weinstein
and he's like I know which one was worth
because it which which one was worse
because at least with the kidnapping
they had a reason behind it so he's
really not a fan of working with uh with
the weinsteins no and I guess um
apparently uh near Sorvino who obviously
also had issues because everybody had
issues with Harvey Weinstein kind of
helped like like she intervened and um
and and basically convinced Harvey to
not fire Guillermo but I also heard that
Guillermo Todo was friends with is
friends with James Cameron and I guess
uh because of how Guillermo was treated
by the weinsteins and Miramax uh James
Cameron almost got into a fight with
Harvey Weinstein at the 70th Academy
Awards so that would have been very
funny to see in modern times with
Twitter I remember hearing that story
yeah I do remember hearing that
um is is James Cameron looking to make a
stand but yeah because well because like
I mean that this is the problem that I
have with Executives not all of them but
a lot of them are like uh the wine
scenes of the world they're like oh I
need more jump scares right or or give
me this idiotic happy ending that
doesn't make any sense so for those of
you listening if you don't know uh Del
Toro obviously did not like uh or or
approve of the film as it was released
but he later did a director's cut yeah
and and and the director's cut certainly
more of his stamp on it and so you can
kind of feel that that awkwardness when
you go back and watch the original
versus the director's cut the way that
Delta wanted to tell the story versus
the way that the studio did and those
are sort of the battles that you you
sort of pick and choose as a filmmaker
because again you you look at each movie
as an opportunity but it also when
you're building a career like he was in
the 90s everything is a stepping stone
and mimic came out and it wasn't a giant
smash uh by any stretch of the
imagination but I think that it did just
enough to get him the gig with making
something like Blade 2 where that comes
out in 2002 and that's after the Devil's
Backbone and so you know you make your
Studio Movie you go back to your roots
sort of with uh with Devil's Backbone
but he also in that time period had
Hellboy come out and Hellboy it was two
years late it was 2004 is when that one
came out and so I feel like the Hellboy
movies as companion pieces are
significant of the arrival of Del Toro
as far as the filmmaker and the vision
that he wanted to convey now the famous
thing with Hellboy films is that they
made some money but they cost a lot to
put together and when you see the movies
particularly Hellboy 2 the Golden Army
that that I do agree with the Tomato
Meter there I think that's the better
film than the first one but when you
watch either one of these movies darina
the imagination that is just dripping
off of every frame it's incredible
there's no stone unturned there's no
Corner that is just left to uh whatever
we'll do with it later there's so much
care and craft that goes into these
movies and I think the Hellboy films are
the best example of just sort of opening
up the brain of Guillermo del Toro and
taking a look at what's inside there
totally uh it's actually kind of similar
to what happened with Tim Burton's
Batman movies where he made this first
uh he made the first Batman and it was
very successful they kind of just let
him do whatever he wanted with Batman
Returns which is a masterpiece and I
will fight anyone as you know that
Michael King says Batman Batman Returns
is the best Batman movie fight me it's
okay you're gonna love the episode that
we dropped a few weeks ago because we
did celebrate Batman Returns and we I
still think 89 is is a is a better movie
but Batman Returns is I think it's the
highest rated none of those four films
from Batman through Batman and Robin
obviously Batman Returns is the highest
rated on the Tomato Meter so there you
go well look at Rotten Tomatoes being
right again but yeah yeah it's similar
to that where uh Hellboy I it looks
freaking great man like we get a cool
giant HP Lovecraft tentacle Monster at
the End like it's it's I mean this is
I'm sure Guillermo was like this is my
dream I have all this money uh I have
Executives that are kind of letting me
do what I want I want finally like
Hellboy himself looks amazing Ron
Perlman looks like such a badass uh and
you would think like a Mike creature
that Mike mignola created uh how would
that translate to film that's not easy
to not you know to make an actual
Hellboy not look ridiculous uh on a film
adaptation so I think that Guillermo did
a great job but I do like the second the
sequel one better similar to Batman
Returns like I think Guillermo here was
like I get to create the world of my
dream since I was a kid and that's why
you see like 22 different Monsters
Everywhere and um I love um how cheesy
it gets one of my favorite scenes is uh
when Hellboy is uh getting drunk on
Tecate with Abe Sapien and they're
singing a Barry Manilow I can't smile
without you you know like it's just such
a fun movie and it kind of made a lot of
uh Hellboy fans mad because of that uh
but I loved it I think it's great
especially I especially love the scene
do you know when they're in the out uh
in the market and there's that dude
Hellboy too yeah you know when they're
uh they have uh there's that dude that
has like a monster and it has like a
little freaking baby coming out of him
and and the baby's like I'm not a baby
I'm a tumor yes yes
don't take me anymore chicken who bought
the Tooth Fairy French Nevada you say
prince Noida broke the truce and now
there is talk of her I love the human
world
sorry kid that's all right
look nice baby I'm not a baby I'm a
tumor
talking tumor movie how can you how can
you not like that I'm glad you brought
up Abe Sapien too because of all of The
Splendid Creations that Doug Jones the
actor has inhabited I feel like Abe
Sapien just lends so much to those
because these equal parts I mean look
he's amphibious so he's kind of like the
creature in the shape of water but he
also has this this like C-3PO kind of
quality where just a little nerdy dorky
but also it acts as some comic relief
sometimes in the movies and it's a great
balance to all of the the the creatures
that we're seeing the darkness that
we're seeing I mean hellboy's own
backstory is is just a harrowing tale
and so to have Abe sapi in there just to
kind of elevate the mood a little bit I
think it's just the perfect compliment
to help it works in the comics and it
certainly works on the big screen
totally yeah no I really like those two
music especially for the time of uh you
know pre MCU and and and how we get very
kind of formulaic assembly line
superhero movies now as much as I love
end game in another one
um I I just think that they're really
fun uh a little bit hollywood-esque but
but still uh very fun superhero movies
that are not are very unique especially
for its time they're very different than
a lot of the stuff that was coming out
from like you know Marvel and DC so I
think they're pretty solid movies and um
I think they do deserve a number five
and six let's talk about the movie that
hit it number seven and that is
Nightmare owie and that's a movie that I
was super looking forward to because the
cast is second to none I mean you got
your Bradley Cooper you got your cape
Blanchette amongst others and then you
have this premise that is is borrowed
from a previous film and then you also
have Del Toro lending his style to it I
felt like this movie and there's a black
and white version that's good that's
sort of going around that he's screened
a little bit that I got to see a little
bit of and I think it the black and
white even works better obviously that's
not the way that they should release the
movie I'm glad they released it in
glorious Technicolor to begin with so
that you know you can get people in the
theater because black and white is just
so oh I don't know is this too artsy for
me but when you go back and watch
nightmare now we check it out if you
ever get a chance to watch the Black and
White Version it adds so much more to it
because there's sort of less you can
make out and it makes it a little
scarier and it also just gets you into
this sort of vibe of this weird freakish
fun house Carnival kind of really the
Dark Side of Carney life what was your
take on nightmare alley when you saw it
I really liked it um and uh thanks for
pointing out the Black and White Version
because I obviously must see Cate
Blanchett in black and white
no I thought it was great and um and
different from his stuff in the sense
that it seems like most of his move like
you can see kind of you know the and a
director maturing uh in night morale
like you you can see how like he started
you know back in the day when he made
Chronos his first feature film was
obviously about existential inks right
and and uh the whole the whole story of
the movie the premise is basically this
man prolonging his is life no matter
what and so a lot of the themes in
Guillermo's movies are you know anti-uh
Authority right anti-fascism uh you know
basically he's he's very much like a lot
of us Mexicans uh that are into horror
that we are you know uh anti-religion
anti-anything that's institutionalized
right whether it's uh Society whether
it's religion whether it's anything
that's like basically making uh people
live in an unnatural way right and so it
with nightmare alley he takes us to this
story of a basically a grifter right
that's kind of uh being conniving to
people and um and you you kind of expect
in his movies to have these either uh
very heartbreaking endings like Pan's
Labyrinth but or very happy endings and
so I thought this was a very different
uh uh story that he told that's more
about uh greed and power right and and
the choices that somebody can make to
and how those choices and those
decisions that you make throughout your
life actually kind of tell your story
and how it's going to end right and how
you have to face those decisions and so
I thought I thought it not only looked
freaking cool because all his movies
look cool but I just thought it was like
a cool take on what's going on in the
world and and you know people's belief
systems and and how they're trying to to
grift human beings all the time just
because they want more and more and more
and they're not satisfied with all the
power and money that they have it's a
it's an excellent point you make about
just his his sort of viewpoint as a
filmmaker and the messaging that he
tries to get across and I think succeeds
even if we're not walking out of the
theater talking about man that was some
really good anti-fascist material
because you're talking about the
creatures and all the Fantastical stuff
it does kind of stick to your ribs a
little bit the the themes that he's
putting into his movies so finally here
I want to take you back to Chronos and I
want you to Arena to sort of like it
just put us in the in the frame of mind
that you were in when when when you
heard of this movie when you saw this
movie for the first time and how you
would sell this movie to people who are
fans of Del Toro now but maybe haven't
gone back and checked out his back
catalog quite as extensively what is it
about Kronos that that made you see the
potential in a filmmaker like gamma Del
Toro like this guy can do this with
basically a shoestring budget imagine
what he can do once we give him billions
of dollars to create these Fantastical
worlds look if you're like me and you
grew up in the 80s and 90s with vampire
stories like Bram Stoker's Dracula and
Interview with a Vampire where vampires
are actually real and scary or and more
like Nosferatu as opposed to the modern
uh generation who grew up with Twilight
this is the movie for you This is the
End Chronos is basically the
anti-twilite uh Guillermo de toro
actually really hates Vamp when people
portray vampires as sexualized creatures
right because to him the the uh the
actual idea of a vampire is scary
because all they care about is having
more life and they'll go to super
extreme lengths uh than anybody else to
stay alive and so it's about it's more
about the seductiveness of immortality
right uh versus just getting it on with
a sparkly dude that doesn't eat people
so he's not a real vampire no dig to
Robert Patterson because they're good
actors but uh I I really like this movie
like it's not for everybody I think it
was made in 1993 is when it came out
like I was 11. so obviously when I saw
it I was like this is really cool but
I'm not sure uh if you've never seen it
um if if you're not into old movies
depending on what generation you are you
would you would like it unless you're
like me where you're like anti-twiling
and you love Nosferatu and it's more
about like existential angst and and the
lengths that a man will go to stay alive
even though you're not really living a
truly like fulfilling life it's so funny
you bring that up because I I start to
think about it in terms of like the
horror movies that really influence me
because when you're a kid and you see a
horror movie there there's always that
one flicking for me it might have just
been this might be hacky it might have
been The Exorcist where I've seen horror
movies before but that's the first time
where I started to get the layered
meaning of this and and I started to get
deeper into what the story was actually
telling us as opposed to just the scary
visuals because I like you you wait
until your your parents fall asleep then
you sneak downstairs me and my older
sister would try to watch movies like on
USA up all night so we caught it's alive
the baby killer movie the the the killer
is the baby and then my aunt took us to
see pet cemetery we were way too young
and that was a nice little furthering of
my matriculation to horror but then the
Exorcist and those movies like Chronos
for you are sort of those benchmarks of
how you see films the kind of movies
that you want to see and it it's fun to
hear an impressionable darena uh watch
something like Kronos and just sort of
take that in and I feel like knowing you
like I do now that really sort of
informed your outlook and and what your
goals with art consumption are totally
yeah no I mean it's it's it's so strange
and awesome at the same time to see this
man
um you know uh just be kind of like uh
or like Alfonso cuaron right where like
you you heard of these people as a kid
growing up in Mexico
um and you're like oh like these you
know these are people that seem talented
and not to see them become very
successful uh in Hollywood and win
Oscars like it's it makes you feel uh
good because it you relate for me I
obviously relate to these people right
like a lot of kids that grow up in a
very structured
um Society end up creating creating art
that helps you know little kids
um kind of like not feel like outcasts
right like from the Tim Burtons to the
Guillermo and Torres of the world like
um I think that this is kind of what
helps a lot of people survive when
they're in darkness right so I'm a huge
fan of this man and um and for sure he's
he definitely has made an impression and
I'm looking forward to seeing what else
he's he's got because what a talent I
know you and the World Girls Just you
all just keep pumping out great content
and your new podcast offshoot [ __ ] out
of water y'all get into some like more
serious stuff and I've heard a couple of
the episodes and it's really good the
three of you just sort of it's it's like
you get deeper into a societal issue
into your own background and having the
three of you together makes it just feel
like a safe space but you're also really
you're opening up a new side of
yourselves to the world well you know uh
if you guys haven't heard uh because
we're very new we've only been around
for like a couple years uh it's the
little startup that could through the
pandemic uh the world girls and it
literally we just give things a whirl is
Roxy star stuff so bra and me and uh and
we're all very different girls with very
different backgrounds uh that have
seemed to have a good chemistry and
complement each other uh in the best way
possible uh even though you know Roxy is
a Patriots fan and you know you you
gotta love your enemies it's okay can't
do it okay it's very sad but um she's
from Boston so she has the excuse but uh
you know it's it's it's a it's a weird
concept that just started as like we
give things a whirl kind of like the try
guys and jackass and it became this
amazing little Community uh our audience
is so cool and you usually don't get to
see cool uh uh you know internet people
is usually internet trolls we're very
proud of our community we kind of call
ourselves uh sexy Mr Rogers because
we're trying to spread joy and love and
tolerance and the only thing we don't
tolerate is intolerance and so we're
very proud of what we've done and and
we've gone from you know taking steps
abroad to Halloween Horror Nights at
Universal Studios and having her you
know run from a chainsaw man to now
doing a podcast where we talk about you
know uh grieving and uh you know
polyamorous relationships and uh and
also we recently just did a a podcast on
Growing Up Catholic right because that's
a whole other animal that Guillermo de
toro can definitely identify with so uh
so it's been fun so so if you guys want
to catch us we're everywhere we're on
the YouTubes we're on all podcast
platforms uh [ __ ] out of water just
came out this year uh so give it a
listen and uh we're also on all the
social medias uh at the world rules that
is Dorene Ariano she's just uh she's
such a sweetheart she's such a dark soul
and it's just a nice mesh of everything
together it kind of like if Cameron Del
Toro could make the perfect human he
probably would make darina so dorina we
say thank you and good night um to you
and once again you can email us RT is
wrong at rottentomatoes.com be like our
friend Leo Douglas uh this podcast is
able to subscribe rate review share
whatever your platform of choice as you
do go ahead and do it for us we really
appreciate it next week's episode I
imagine Duran would have some thoughts
on this as well we're tackling the
entire franchise that takes place on a
quiet little Suburban Street known as
Elm Street Nightmare on Elm Street the
entire franchise the highs the lows the
Dream Warriors my favorite one will
anybody agree with me that is going to
be determined next week in the meantime
for everyone here at Rotten Tomatoes our
our new welcome to the crew for Glenn we
also have super engineer Brian producy
Lucy Jacqueline Coley the whole gang at
rt.com including Alex Vo who put
together that wonderful gimmer Del Toro
countdown editorial I am merely Mark
Ellis for the great Durant Ariana and
the World Girls thanks for listening to
this episode code of Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong we'll see you next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]